dead come to town we go to the parking
lot everybody's getting their opium
their weed their acid or whatever
selling peanut butter and jellies
whatever drug salads right totally I
grew up in Maryland so you know heavy
metal parking lot I'm sure you know that
video okay those kids are a little older
than me but same people you know those
kids had kids so I went to see you guys
probably early 2000s at The Forum who
came back on tour I go to see you guys
at the Forum and I get to the parking
lot and it's like 1980 all over again
I'm like oh my God it was like all those
people came from wherever the [__] they
live in Southern California and
collected in this one parking lot it was
Camaros and everything else it was the
best